seit ungefähr eineinhalb Jahren ein
bisschen mehr mache ich Kochvideos hier
auf Youtube und das war für mich lange
nicht selbstverständlich dass ich in
diesem Bereich enden würde um genau zu
sein ziemlich genau vor zwei Jahren habe
ich überlegt aus meiner Wohnung in der
meine bisherige Küche stand auszuziehen
weil
ich einfach keinen Spaß mehr in Youtube
hatte keine Videos mehr hatte kein Geld
mehr hatte teure Miete hatte selbst
erklärend irgendwas hat mir gesagt nee
mach's nicht so bleibt bleibt da einfach
noch ein bisschen wohnen das wird schon
alles und in der Zeit habe ich auch
vermehrt Spaß am Kochen gefunden und
genau das hat irgendwie auch dazu
geführt dass schon alles geklappt hat
weil ich hatte Lust auf kochen ihr
hattet Lust auf Kochen ich habe Videos
daraus gemacht und der Rest ist
Geschichte warum ich so sentimental bin
ist weil hinter mir meine neue Küche
steht und die ist wirklich mehr als ich
mir heute aber auch vor zwei Jahren
hätte träumen können mein erstes
richtiges kochvideo ein Tag persönlicher
Koch für Gewitter im Kopf habe ich
natürlich meine alten Küche aufgenommen
wie gesagt meine alte Küche war in
meiner eigenen Wohnung so ich habe in
der gleichen Küche gefrühstückt in der
ich gedreht habe ich habe ganz viele
Gäste empfangen die ich bekocht habe ich
habe verrückte Rezepte ausprobiert ich
habe mit Dutzenden von Stunden einzelne
Gerichte ausprobiert und einfach sehr
sehr viel Spaß gehabt in dieser Küche
Geschichten wurden geschrieben erik ist
auf meinen Kanal zugestoßen und seitdem
ein fester Bestandteil es ist einfach es
hat schon weh getan dann irgendwie
umzuziehen und genau diese Realisation
hatten wir bestanden in der Küche und
wir waren
ey wir ziehen gerade um so wir packen
gerade unsere Sachen und dann sind wir
weg hier dabei ist das meine private
Wohnung in der ich halt noch lebe und in
der ich auch koche und meine Zeit
verbringe aber das war schon krass was
weißt du was denn
tatsächlich so komisch angefühlt wir
haben drüber gesprochen und dann haben
wir identifiziert wir ziehen gerade um
dass man sagt so tschüss
aber es ist ein großer Schritt das Wort
Umzug ist so groß es ist groß aber es
ist nicht geringer sein aber warum
brauchen wir eine neue Küche zum einen
weil es nicht das beste der Welt ist
wenn man in seiner Wohnung arbeitet und
seine Wohnung verwüstet wenn man
irgendwelche aufwendigen Rezepte
ausprobiert und drei Gerichte an einem
Tag kocht und dann ignoriert man zwei
Tage lang den spülberg und dann macht
irgendwann nicht so viel Spaß zum
anderen weil wir auch Youtube technisch
limitiert waren so wir konnten nicht
alles machen was wir wollten die Küche
war begrenzt groß die zum Beispiel
spiegelnde Oberflächen über die sich
Eric schon seit Tag eins aufgeregt hat
und wir vielleicht wisst bin ich seit
Anfang diesen Jahres hier in Halle 2 und
in Halle 2 war von Anfang an für mich
klar werde ich eine studioküche haben
weil ich all das noch besser machen
möchte für mich und für euch und wie
soll ich sagen ich habe keine Kosten und
keine Mühen gescheut das hier ist meine
neue Küche
[Musik]
und ich meine ihr seht selbst es ist
kaum in Worte zu fassen ich habe mir
gerade dieses Bild angeschaut und ich
dachte mir das kann nicht sein aber es
ist wahr und es war ein langer Weg bis
hierhin deshalb möchte ich ihn euch
Schritt für Schritt erklären insgesamt
gibt es 8 Schritte wir starten mit
Schritt eins der Planung und wie das so
oft ist wenn ich etwas mache wenn Dave
mit dem ich im Büro ist etwas macht es
gibt keine Planung wir machen einfach
drauflos wir sind in dieser Halle hier
hineingekommen sie war leer also es gab
keine Wände es gab keine Räume es gab
keine Küche keine Büros kein Nichts und
mit unserem Übermut haben wir gesagt das
machen wir einfach selbst deshalb haben
wir angefangen haben uns mit Tobi
getroffen kreativ Tobi absolute Legende
hat auch ein einzelnes Video zu meiner
Küche gemacht welches ich euch verlinken
werde und wir haben einfach gemacht wir
haben einfach angefangen unter Tobis
Anweisung Wände gezogen im Endeffekt
standen wer schlecht als recht ein paar
Wende hier in unserer Halle ja und als
dann die Wände da waren war auch
plötzlich der Raum da der Raum für eine
Küche und genauso wichtig war es halt
auch dass die Küche die in diesem Raum
hier steht geplant ist ein bisschen
besser als wir den Rest geplant haben
deshalb habe ich mich lange nach einem
Küchenstudio umgeschaut und habe mich in
diese Küche verliebt ich habe sie
gesehen im SieMatic Studio am Neumarkt
wo gemerkt ich habe die Küche selbst
bezahlt oder aber wahnsinnig gut beraten
und habe auch ein Rabatt bekommen auf
die Küche deshalb danke schön und ich
war mit Eric dort wir haben uns
angeschaut und wir haben uns für diese
Küche entschieden aber es gab noch
einige Anpassungen zu machen wir mussten
viele viele Dinge in der Planung für die
Küche berücksichtigen das Wichtigste ist
dass sie funktional ist dass wir hier
gut arbeiten können gut kochen können
natürlich geht es fast noch wichtiger
darum dass sie schön aussieht auf Kamera
glaube das tut sie und sie soll auch
nicht nur in einem Winkel gut aussehen
sondern wir müssen aus jedem Winkel eine
Kamera aufstellen können und es sieht
gut aus ich glaube das tut es und zwar
ganz klar wenn wir diesen Schritt gehen
neue Küche dann wird das eine neue
Etappe dann wird das ein neuer
Meilenstein deshalb kam auch in letzter
Zeit weniger Kochvideos weil diese Küche
war hier noch nicht ganz fertig und wir
wussten es wird alles anders deshalb
konnten wir nicht mehr in der alten
Küche drehen das war und Segen weil wir
haben uns wirklich in allem Mühe gegeben
und wollten bei allem dass es perfekt
ist das hat auch die Planung erschwert
und wir kommen zu Punkt 2 der Umsetzung
diese Wände hier sind nicht echt Beton
das hat Tobi auf den ich gerade
eingegangen bin gezaubert gemeinsam mit
seinem Vater waren die hier haben ganze
Arbeit geleistet und es greift einfach
so perfekt Hand in Hand in sich mit den
Oberflächen von der Küche und so und ich
habe auch wirklich schon Leute hier drin
gehabt die haben gemeint so ist das kein
Beton wirklich nicht weil es sind ganz
normale Wände gewesen Betonoptik zack
zack wenn ihr wissen wollt wie es
verlinkt aber es gibt auch andere
Gegebenheiten die in der Umsetzung
geschaffen werden mussten schau dort
geht an Carlo der den Wasserhahn
angeschlossen hat schaut dort geht ein
Elektro Görg die immer da waren um Herde
und sonst was anzuschließen wir merkt
ich werde wahrscheinlich viel danke
sagen in diesem Video deshalb möchte ich
noch mal Schritt zurückgehen da erstmal
euch danke sagen weil das ernst nicht
selbstverständlich so und das ist eine
abgedroschende Phrase aber ich möchte
dass ihr das versteht so dass es echt
was besonderes auch für mich so hier zu
sein und das so meine Küche nennen zu
dürfen und hier arbeiten dürfen deshalb
Dankeschön und ihr könnt euch selbst
denken ich bin seit Anfang diesen Jahres
hier in Halle 2 seitdem ist das hier
unser neues Büro wir haben jetzt bitte
September da gab es einige Probleme es
gab Probleme mit Anschlüssen die noch
nicht da waren es gab Probleme mit
defekten Bauteilen mit Lieferzeiten
eigentlich gab es nur Probleme aber wir
alle hier hatten eigentlich nur ein Ziel
vor Augen dass die Küche steht und dass
wir geilen Content aus dieser Küche
liefern können der nächste Punkt ist
eine Frage warum so warum ist die Küche
so wie sie jetzt aussieht weil ich würde
sagen nicht viele Küchen sehen so aus
diese verschieden hohen Arbeitsflächen
die Kräutergärten das Buffet die
Abstände die zwischendrin sind und die
Antwort ist wegen euch also es soll
einfach interessant anzusehen sein nicht
nur interessant sondern auch schön also
keine Sorge auch wenn ich hier in die
Küche reinkomme denke ich mir so was ist
das hier aber das ermöglicht so viel mit
der Kamera so dass das eigentlich der
treibende Grund für diese Form der Küche
aber warum haben wir zum Beispiel zwei
Kochfelder naja weil im Hintergrund
Sachen köcheln während ich im
Vordergrund was anderes mache so das
braucht wahrscheinlich sonst kaum jemand
in seiner Küche aber hier ist es halt
notwendig genauso dass ich quasi zwei
Backöfen habe manchmal mache ich fünf
Sachen gleichzeitig wenn ich so ein
Video drehe und hier kann ich es halt
endlich meine anderen Küche war das
immer Kopfschmerzen das Buffet hinter
mir nicht nur ein schöner Ort für meine
Kaffeemaschine sondern bildet ein
Hintergrund für diese Perspektive also
deshalb so Punkt 4 die Klimatisierung
ihr fragt euch vielleicht warum ist sie
nötig wir sitzen quasi in einem
Gewächshaus hier oben haben wir eine
Dachkuppel im gesamten Büro haben wir
Dachkuppeln und die haben ganz schnell
gemerkt wie heißt es hier wird und
insbesondere hier in der Küche wird es
heiß nicht nur weil die Herde heiß sind
sondern weil hier ganz ganz viel Technik
noch verbaut wird deshalb haben wir auch
hier in der Küche eine Klimaanlage und
das ist halt ein absoluter Luxus sowie
alles hier in der Küche ein großer Luxus
ist aber wir haben uns hier so gefühlt
den perfekten Ort gebaut um die besten
Videos zu die wir machen können deshalb
geht das nächste Dankeschön an Firma
Nordhoff die jungs ihr habt sie in Daves
Blogs kennengelernt sind der absolute
Wahnsinn sind hier reingekommen haben
uns unser Leben gerettet und wirklich
bestmögliche Arbeit verrichtet kommen
wir zur Technik die hier in der Küche
steckt und das ist jede Menge wie gesagt
wir haben zwei Herren ich habe mich bei
beiden Herren für Herde der Marke Bora
entschieden auch hier wieder bezahlt
warum für diese Herde weil sie ein
eingelassenen Dunstabzug haben falls ihr
euch erinnert in meiner alten Küche habe
ich immer auf diesen kleinen Kochplatten
gekocht ich hatte gar keinen Abzug und
wenn ich es getan hätte dann hätte ich
so einen normalen deckenabzug gehabt der
mir irgendwo im Gesicht hängt beide
Herde sind Induktionsherde ich habe mich
zwischen Induktion und Gas entschieden
für Induktion zum Glück weil bei Gas
muss man ja nichts mehr sagen in der
aktuellen Zeit Induktion ist schnell ich
muss keine Flaschen kaufen hier liegt
halt keine Gasleitung an dementsprechend
war Induktionen der einzige und richtige
Weg deswegen habe ich ihn gewählt wir
haben zwei Backöfen bzw wenn man
hinschaut haben wir ein Backofen und ein
Dampfbackofen
ich weiß nicht ob ich einen Dampf Ofen
brauche aber ich dachte mir es ist
sinnvoller als zwei Backöfen wir werden
die ganzen der Küche noch erleben oder
hoffentlich nicht erleben ich habe mich
aber auch ganz bewusst gegen so fancy
Sachen entschieden wieso Teppanyaki
Grills die so in die Platte eingelassen
sind oder nach Induktions Wok Station
weil am Ende des Tages mache ich ja
Videos bei denen ich will und ihr
hoffentlich auch dass ihr es nachmachen
könnt und deshalb all die tollen Sachen
die vielleicht cool gewesen wären habe
ich einfach rausgelassen ich habe mich
auch immer abgefuckt wenn ich Kochvideos
gesehen habe und dann haben wir
irgendeinen futuristisches Gerät dass
man unbedingt braucht wir machen das
hier alles ganz normalen Sachen und zu
guter letzt noch der kucker daraus
können wir jegliche Art von Wasser
ziehen das heißt gekühltes stilles
Wasser gekühltes Sprudelwasser kochendes
Wasser und normales wasserhahnwasser von
kalt bis fast heiß ultra nützlich wir
müssen keine Wasserkisten mehr kaufen
wir kriegen das einfach aus der Leitung
das Kochen geht schneller wenn man
irgendwie mal Heißwasser braucht um sich
schnell paar Nudeln zu machen oder so
und alles in allem auch eine absolute
Bereicherung für den Koch und
Küchenalltag ja dann sind wir noch mit
den Tools eskaliert ich habe dadurch
dass ich in vielen verschiedenen Küchen
war gelernt welche Küchenwerkzeuge
wirklich gut sind welche wirklich
wichtig zu haben sind und was einem
fehlt wenn man es nicht hat wenn man es
schon mal benutzt hat ich glaube ihr
versteht was ich meine der nächste Punkt
sind weitere Sets und hier seid ihr
gefragt weil vielleicht habt ihr gute
Ideen wir haben hier nämlich noch zwei
Ecken die frei sind die komplett
gestaltet werden können und ihr könnt
gerne überlegen was was später reinhauen
können hier können wir auf jeden Fall
gemeinsam kreativ werden so was würdet
ihr gerne sehen was kennt ihr vielleicht
was cool aussieht schreibt einfach mal
in die Kommentare weil vielleicht wird
eure Idee umgesetzt und ihr gestaltet
die Küche mit immer aber auch sicher
dass auch aus den zwei Ecken noch mehr
rauszuholen wird und das wird wirklich
so der einzige Ort in dem ich mich
aufhalte wenn ihr gute Ideen habt immer
her damit und der letzte Punkt Nummer 8
der Ausblick was passiert hier diese
Küche und da kann ich für Erik und mich
sprechen ist zwar nur ein Werkzeug aber
dieses Werkzeug hat uns so viel gegeben
jetzt schon so viel Motivation so viel
Drive so viel Kreativität um Vollgas zu
geben um noch viel mehr aus dem ganzen
hier rauszuholen als wir eh schon
bekommen könnte zufrieden sein so es
geht mir wirklich besser denn je
wahrscheinlich so aber ich finde ich
schulde euch und ich schulde mir und wir
schulden uns keinen Stillstand es geht
weiter wir gehen weiter voran wir werden
wirklich kranke Videos aus dieser Küche
machen hoffentlich Videos machen die ihr
noch nie so gesehen habt und wir werden
ganz viel Spaß dabei haben es wird eine
kranke Zeit mit Sicherheit werde ich
auch immer mal wieder ein Update Video
machen über die Küche weil sich noch
viel tun wird aber für den jetzigen
Moment bin ich einfach nur dankbar ich
bin dankbar hier zu sitzen und ja
deshalb ihr habt die Küche gesehen ich
hoffe ihr liebt sie genauso sehr wie wir
es war jetzt ein besonderes Video weil
es auch irgendwie so eine besondere
Ebene das ist
fast krasser oder besonderer für mich
als eine Millionen Abos so weil das
zeigt mir viel mehr wie weit wir
gekommen sind
sehr sehr geil okay bis zum nächsten Mal
wenn ihr diese tollen Videos aus der
neuen Küche nicht verpassen wollt dann
abonniert den Kanal aktiviert die Glocke
und
hier drüben hier ist ein für dich
vorgeschlagenes Video sowas mache ich
nämlich jetzt auch danke schön und bis
zum nächsten Mal ciao
[Musik]